[Music]
in my bad news one of my favorite two
words which ones my bad in mine
my bad submitted by the only Steve oh
wow that's controversial yeah but my
Steve or Steven my gosh do I go my
Steven he knows with a pH so no you
don't I do about it
ste Phe yeah oh I mean you felt you
spelled Steve with yeah I wish you would
yeah right Robbie great why did you
choose Steve when I was a kid writing my
name like Steven and having people call
me Steven it just made me think of my
mom like lecturing me so Steve got
easier and easier as I grew up my mom
named me Nicole to call me Nicky but you
just Nick
no she never called me Nicole huh what
about you why why you go by Stephen Oh
Stephen cuz that's my name okay here's
the thing though explain this to me why
do white people tend to call me Steve
and Asian people hadn't call me Stephen
like when they person meet me I don't
know why do you introduce yourself as
Stephen yes that's why minded then why
people still call you Steve but then
what people will just like cut off the
inferred whatever I have a friend whose
name is Daniel and I only call him dead
and he's asked me to call him Daniel and
I just can't I don't know how to do it
what is it in white people's blood it's
more casual like I say Stephen is so
form to normal yeah like so if I want to
be your friend I'm just gonna call you
by your nickname or a nickname what's
even more annoying than that check this
out
there's multiple David's that I'm
associated with right
but I'm always David so that's true I
never thought David yeah I'm always
David so why the [ __ ] am I not Dave
because it's easy
so is easy I've always been Steve green
to maker studios there's all 16 green
it's always high school Steve that way I
think so there's not too many
Niki's but everyone calls me Nikki limo
cuz your name
it's fun to say see that's why I think
about your name oh I think your name is
very fun there yeah well I feel great
now you just flipped one of my childhood
you're born in Singapore right uh we're
in Ohio my family's from Malaysia
rongkhun five segments of you doing that
it's okay
a woman paid $1,000 in airline fees
after she accidentally marked herself as
a terrorist on travel for what box
that's on the forum exactly the people
are saying like what Florida it gets a
little it gets more terrorists a year
yeah maybe it's like I am here for
terrorist acts yes I like okay go get
them yeah yeah the question says do you
seek and do you seek to engage in or
have you ever engaged in terrorist
activities espionage sabotage or a
genocide holy [ __ ] that's funny
like people are gonna be like espionage
well I did help the Russians some you
know or whatever I was like who's gonna
[ __ ] right back
honest the most honest terrorists maybe
they have to be honest it's part of the
terrorist code it's like a code like if
somebody knew terrorists you can't say
I'm not a terrorist like a undercover
cop the week Terry they're in a media
they're like yes we are terrorists but
we have honor then why'd you stop being
a terrorist because I was the worst
terrorist ever so I'm going to click yes
or if you're a funny white guy you're
like yeah I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] terrorist
yeah okay you're still going to jail me
you can't write this [ __ ] that's right
baby what about if you were a part of
the genocide but not a on the receiving
end but you survived you engaged in
genocide Wow I don't have nothing being
engaged in genocide because you would
have got genocided
you can't even fill out the form you
were the victim of the genocide you
would not be there to fill it
so they were say you survived you
survived the general sense the previous
box actually maybe it's funny that you
picked that up not the fact that it was
we're talking about Genesis anyway so
this woman here she's a breast cancer
patient her name is Mandy she's 29 years
old she has this bucket list that she
started doing with her boyfriend one of
the things on her list was to go to New
York
and so she started filling out a visa
from what country because she's from
Scotland okay filling out a visa and
then on her electronic system for Travel
Authorization form or est a form she
accidentally clicked yes for the
terrorist thing and that just it just
[ __ ] things up hurt like so many times
so she had to go through two more
interviews I hope she looks normal as
bugs like I hope she looks like oh my
god but you were gonna say on her bucket
list one of the things that she wanted
to tear as a plane no no I'm imagining
just like when she's on the forum right
a pop-up comes up it's like it like gets
you at the right time right when you
look like no it just moves - yes that's
actually kind of what happens I wasn't
calibrated correctly yeah yeah she said
that she was trying to like click Next
or something and then that somehow it
like glitched and it made her click on
guess she didn't realize it and then she
just kept moving on and that also
happened during her haircut I heard she
was getting her hair cut and then she
accidentally clicked through the Ringo
Starr it's this table man look I can
talk about people's hair cuz I'm hair
disadvantage
[Laughter]
and II can't that's right you've been
having better not hear a word from you
or you or you really see your mommy
right now you just have a large forehead
that's it exactly Thank You TIF burned
in a house you're there and the rest of
your body oh my got it buddy see what's
your problem no I know what harnesses
until you say something then no litter
it's not true are you out of your mind
no they all don't know everyone knows
good stuff because they've been me yeah
you brought attention you brought
attention like me with my ears I was
dumb and crazy for blowing up a rhythm
yep your ears are huge though compared
to me you [ __ ] freak you literally I
had no idea about your hair problems are
you [ __ ] compare my heavier ears you
monster don't do that that's offensive
can we remove that from the video Jess
thank you I'm so offended right now what
the [ __ ] my hair is not like your ears
dude this girl she had to pay over a
thousand dollars to get her flight
rescheduled because of all of this of
course they don't want a terrorist on
board it kinda sucks cashews in she's
getting chemo and stuff so she's like in
12 cycles you got the plan oh it's a wig
I didn't hear that part
wait a minute so you're telling me she's
already going through chemo and then
they sent a robot up her ass because she
actually sent up cooked a terrorist
thing like that's crazy man so what does
she have to do to kind of reverse this
[ __ ] like it's a fact like what did you
have to do to prove that she's not a
terrorist
what kind of [ __ ] questions are they
ask so like so you were a terrorist or a
genocide like do or like whatever was a
[ __ ] spy yeah well I mean she
obviously had to like go there and be
like oh because her thing got rejected
that's how she found out about the whole
accidental ad you can't fly yes
got to just like go and be like look it
was an accident and all this stuff
you're like all the terrorism was an
accident what was an accident
I accidentally genocided one time in
high school I was a dumb I guess I know
she's been able to rebook her stuff so
she's fine but I personally kind of
think it's funny that this even he mused
because it like this is like there were
headlines made for this actually
accidentally clicked terrorist I think
it's even funny that there's a section
where you can click and admit that
you're a genocide terror sure that means
the funniest thing is that Steve flamed
the chemo patient no but I stand by my
comments no I didn't know it makes it
worse when you breast cancer patient I
mean my shoes and you know what most of
us saw the haricot we just didn't say
anything you can pick a better wig
anyone can that's all I'm saying
you can tell she looks like a member of
the Monkees or something which is cool
yes oh she's from the UK though you know
is it Russia or Germany Germany I think
they all the women cut their hair short
and I one friend was telling me how like
everyone in America thought she was gay
because like of her haircut but like in
Germany
I think it's Germany it's you to Germany
or Russia I can't remember though but
like all the women have their haircuts
like that dude Debbie Morgan it's more
efficient
Danny Moore did that haircut and I [ __ ]
him home though yep she was naked right
so I couldn't it wasn't a ball thing
though I think some girls look good with
it and some girls just don't that's all
I gotta say I think she looks great
okay
we're good man Stephen well I'm not
saying she doesn't look great I'm just
saying she looks hilarious yeah I didn't
say that she just I think she looks
great
Mandy you look great she looks amazing I
only said [ __ ] about her hair maybe
she's a lovely looking man you didn't
say she was ugly I'm just talking about
her hair maybe she spent all the money
on the fine and had nothing left to pay
for a wig maybe that's a good bird
that's a really good he's so big did the
fact is not her hair I was well done
he's like maybe she had no money to pay
for a haircut own I feel bad I get it
good that's a really good point you're
trying to help Mandy
[Music]